for some more insight on the story I'm
now joined by Gannett Sandusky is the
director global diversity and inclusion
aptoide sure bank and a board member at
the charter of diversity Association
good to have you on the show again if
people with disabilities tend to be more
loyal employees and one can understand
the argument why is it so difficulty so
difficult for them to get a job I think
it has to do also with biases biases on
both sides so I see people being biased
that Deutsche Bank for example is not an
inclusive employer for people with
different abilities but I also see
biases at the manager side who say okay
there are so much things to taken into
account from a legal perspective from an
environment perspective working
environment so they are shying back a
bit from really offering actively work
places for people with different
abilities so tell us a little bit more
about the barriers that are out there
except for the steps that are
insurmountable for somebody who's in a
wheelchair for hmm well some of the
barriers are really these so-called
unconscious biases I don't know as a
manager probably how to approach a
colleague but the different ability the
team members maybe share the same
observations or the same problems are
and it's always about building bridges
it's like that these steps you need to
build a bridge to overcome these steps
and then really see the benefit in
having these colleagues having their
brain over the company okay again we'll
talk some more in a minute first holding
down a job earning money and feeling
like an active member of society in
spite of living with a physical
disability these are the goals that are
out of reach for many people around the
world about a billion people around the
globe live with some form of disability
that's around 15% of the world's
population most live in developing
countries
only a small minority of access to
medical care 20 million people would
benefit from a wheelchair but don't have
one most of the world's disabled
children don't go to school later
they'll have almost no chance of finding
a job over a million severely disabled
people were employed in Germany in 2015
most had positions in administration
followed by manufacturing and the
healthcare sector in Germany the
unemployment rate among people with
disabilities has been steadily
decreasing at 13.4 percent however it's
still twice as high as the average rate
of unemployment let's talk some more
with Jared Sandusky gurnard there's a
law in Germany that says companies with
20 employees or more have to give 5
percent of their jobs to people with
disabilities or pay a fine most of the
companies opt to pay a fine with raising
that fine change anything I think it
wouldn't change significantly because as
I just stated it's a question of
behavior it's not just ticking the box
is really your approach are two people
with different abilities or disabled
people are either way on so just raising
this fine wouldn't really make much a
difference we adored your bank for
example do neither nor are although
we're making quite some progress in our
percentage of people with different
abilities we don't need the 5% holder
yet but we then work with sheltered
workshops are - will also support people
with disabilities and their roads well
if you take it companies that are
smaller mid-sized companies yeah and are
they more open to hiring people with
physical disabilities because they may
feel the the pinch of the lack of
skilled workers more at the moment ah
that's probably - but on the other hand
side they also see some more issues with
dealing with all the legal hurdles but
all the requirements are and that's what
for example caught a few fighters also
for to build a network to bring people
together and to share best
and experience that it's not such a
hoarder that it's doable and that you
then have really the benefit out of a
diverse workforce hmm what sort of
untapped potential do you think is out
there in terms of numbers of value or I
think it's with people with different
abilities like with the broader or space
of diversity there is quite some
potential if people can bring their
whole self to work they really will
deliver much more benefit for the
company they were really bringing their
own brain their abilities the experience
if they don't need to hide back if they
no don't need to overcome some sort of
unconscious biases they can really add
to the value of the company and to their
own value Gannett Sandusky we'll
continue our interview in just a moment
now a lot of large companies pride
themselves on fostering diversity in the
workforce but they are not motivated
purely by a sense of social justice some
of it's just good old-fashioned
fashioned business strategy the further
you throw your net the greater the
chance of catching more fish many
societies are growing more diverse in
Germany people now come from all over
the world to study and to work lots of
companies are hiring people from a wider
range of backgrounds
[Music]
Buddha symphonia companies are looking
for a diversity but for us that doesn't
mean primarily diversity among staff
based on visible characteristics it's
more about the creativity experience
knowledge and skills they can contribute
people from more than 60 countries work
at Hankel headquarters and there are
sound business reasons why so many
nations are represented the company
sells body care products and detergents
all over the world and people who come
from Asia or the Middle East know best
what their compatriots want to buy
interesting is that actually when people
come from different backgrounds
different ways of working they bring
with them a lot of expertise from
different markets
henkle has launched an image campaign to
celebrate the diversity it promotes and
addresses haitihub a while ago Henkel
developed a shampoo specifically for
women in Muslim societies we asked what
does someone who hides her hair under a
cloth all they need in terms of special
care do we have to adapt the formula
most deformity much like an English
writer to be had
now then we launched the product on
those markets octave locked does vet
never would have happened if it had just
been a group of Germans sitting around
discussing what to do disposition hi
Jovie dr. Voss [ __ ] German
universities are also promoting
diversity
Anita Benedict Emmanuelle is in her
sixth semester at the University of
Duisburg Essen she's part of a program
that takes on school pupils from
non-academic backgrounds who want to
study and accompanies them through their
time at the university mentoring them
along the way this benefits young people
from German and immigrant families
Anita is the first member of her family
to go to university her parents are from
Sri Lanka when attending Kinsey had
garnished and with dolls my parents
weren't very familiar with the education
system here and even when my teachers
tried to explain it it still wasn't very
clear feared and that's politically the
program gave me the information I needed
and the counselors here at the
university told us about the various
courses of study we could take that was
really helpful yeah I mean that's what
I'm headset wife for many young people
from immigrant backgrounds in Germany
getting ahead depends on getting help
many don't finish high school and only
around 10 percent pursue higher
education so the university also offers
tutoring for school children immigrant
families often do not speak German at
home yet command of the language is a
prerequisite for success six years ago
Mariam fakir II and her family fled to
Germany from Afghanistan she wants to
become an engineer or architect it was
hard at first because I didn't speak the
language and everything was so foreign
to me and you hear people say you'll
never make it but by being in this
program with extra tutoring and help
from teachers and friends who really
motivated me I realized I can make it
yeah this is got something better every
day around 300 youngsters come here for
tutoring and the number of requests far
outstrips the number of available slots
often comas rely on insurance we see a
lot of kids with a lot of potential then
they tell us how their schools deal with
them and it's pretty shocking what does
that oft
it's two other factors also play a role
the first is that they don't get any
support at home their parents think they
don't stand a chance and second they
often have deficits in their knowledge
of German so harnessing diversity is all
about tapping potential whatever a
person's cultural or ethnic background
over the past decades some German
companies have signed up to a diversity
Charter in it they commit to creating
work environments free of bias there are
six dimensions described in the charters
list of voluntary commitments the first
is sex so men and women and then there's
age we usually talk about the five
generations of people active in working
life
then there's nationality and ethnic
origin religion and worldview sexual
orientation and identity and finally
disability bend along the goal is to
give every employee the same
opportunities and if promoting diversity
is also good PR so much the better
[Music]
and we're back with Gannett Sandusky
ganodi you are a member of the board at
the Charter of diversity a voluntary
commitment by German companies to a more
diverse workforce now a recent study
that I read by a recruiting firm shows
that more than 1/3 of the people that
were asked do not want to work and
diverse teams I mean that's a pretty sad
result after more than 10 years of this
voluntary commitment isn't it
well that exactly shows how important it
is to really again and again tell the
story and tell the story about the
benefit of having diverse teams arm and
be as is called our founders deutsche
bank co-founded the quarter a few fold
are and all companies that are joined up
together are really committed that
diverse workforce will bring better
results but you always have to tell the
story why it is good and also be honest
and say it's not easy I myself had the
leadership experience with roughly 120
people very diverse it wasn't easy to to
lead them but we really got the best
results out of it mmm you are also a
diversity manager at Deutsche Bank do
you think this position will at some
point become obsolete because human
resource will just look for good
candidates for a job in all walks of
society well thanks for mentioning this
are one of my sort of mantras is
diversity needs to get out of the
diversity departments needs to go into
the business areas into the areas for
production where revenue generation is
to really get the benefit out of it to
understand where it is linked to clients
arm so that we really can get the most
out of the diverse workforce can attend
our ski thank you so much for your visit
here thank you